ELIZABETH CHOE: OK.
So this is the day
one confessional.
Lecture ended a
couple hours ago.
Just been trying
to do the homework
assignments along
with the students.
Holy cow.
It is really
exhausting to teach.
And three hours goes
by way faster when
you're talking than it does
when you are listening.
I
I think overall, it
could have definitely
been a lot more
catastrophic than it was,
so that's always good.
I think the hardest thing
was just getting people
to be engaged in discussion.
It was just so quiet.
Overall, it was just hard to
get them engaged in discussion.
Jamie was awesome,
but it's funny
because she's taught
middle school,
so she clearly has a very
good handle on facilitating
these kind of things.
Once she got people
to talk, some
of the stuff that
they were saying
was great-- the
conversations that they
were having about their
experiences with online video.
I'm really glad that she
prodded them a little bit more,
whereas I just wanted to give
up after no one said anything.
Yeah, the time goes
by really fast.
I was definitely
pressed for time,
which shouldn't have
surprised me but still did.
And just making sure to leave
breathing room for students.
I mean, I did try to
pace out the video stuff
so that they'd have sort of a
breather from hearing someone
just talk to them
for three hours.
But I do feel like it was just
a super dense lecture today.
I think passing it off with
Chris at the end helped a lot,
but I would have liked
to have more time
to just have students get
up and use the cameras
and maybe work on the
STEM videos during class.
I know a teacher who teaches
high school sociology,
and his philosophy is
just stay one day ahead
on this syllabus from the class.
And I've been
feeling a little bit
like that in terms
of the materials,
but maybe it's just the
adrenaline from day one.
But I do feel like it was OK.
A little nervous for tomorrow
with all the sixth graders.
A lot nervous about tomorrow.
But I've already met the
kids and they're good kids.
It's just a matter
of trying to balance
everything I need to do for
work aside from lecturing.
Now I get it.
Now I get why
professors don't always
want to prioritize lecturing.
It's not that they
don't want to.
It's that there just aren't
enough hours in the day.
I'm going to sleep
like a rock tonight.